[Música]
tenemos mucho en común con nuestros
primates más cercanos pero en
comparación los humanos parecemos algo
desnudos en lugar de un pelaje grueso
que cubra nuestros cuerpos la mayoría
tenemos pelo en nuestras cabezas y en
otros pocos lugares Cómo es que estamos
tan desnudos Por qué tenemos vello donde
tenemos el vello humano y el pelaje
animal están hechos de lo mismo
filamentos de queratina que crecen de
órganos llamados folículos que
atraviesan ciclos de crecimiento y
peladura en los mamíferos el vello se ha
modificado para numerosos fines desde la
suave pelusa que cubre al conejo hasta
las rígidas Púas que protege al
puercoespín pero para muchos mamíferos
el vello crece en dos capas que
consisten de una capa corta de vello
básico cubierto por otra más larga y
protectora
juntos aislan el cuerpo humano y
protegen la
el vello humano por otro lado es una
combinación de estos dos
desafortunadamente los fósiles no
conservan vello lo que dificulta a los
investigadores ubicar cuando Y cómo
nuestros ancestros Perdieron su pelaje
pero los científicos tienen algunas
hipótesis al parecer hace millones de
años en África los primeros homínidos
bajaron de los árboles y adoptaron un
estilo de vida más activo mantenerse
fresco se hizo más importante
con el tiempo desarrollaron más
glándulas sudoríparas que le sirvieron
para perder calor al evaporar la humedad
por la piel de hecho los humanos tienen
10 veces más de esas glándulas que los
chimpancés pero perder bien el calor
mediante el sudor es más difícil con
pelaje los científicos creen que los
primeros humanos perdieron pelaje en
esta era para que la sudoración fuera
más rápida sin embargo si perder vello
fue tan ventajoso Porque todavía tenemos
un poco al parecer hay usos Únicos del
vello en distintas partes del cuerpo
cuando se trata de nuestras cabezas La
regulación de temperatura quizá juega
una parte desde que los primeros humanos
se aventuraron al aire libre sus cabezas
se habrían expuesto al sol ardiente el
cabello largo y grueso protege nuestro
sensible cuero cabelludo y evita que
nuestro cerebro se sobrecaliente el
cabello oscuro rizado protege mejor la
piel contra la radiación solar otros
tipos de cabello evolucionaron Según a
dónde iban los humanos los
investigadores creen que las cejas son
útiles para la comunicación ya que están
encima de músculos faciales activos que
expresan sentimientos se ha demostrado
que las pestañas minimizan el flujo de
aire sobre los ojos evitan resequedad y
atrapan basuras Y quizá el vello facial
es Útil para identificar a lo lejos pero
no lo sabemos la evidencia es escasa en
el mejor de los casos
Por qué tenemos vello en otras zonas más
crudo las axilas los pezones y el pubis
tienen glándulas apocrinas producen
secreciones grasosas y olorosas que el
vello grueso y rizado que allí crece
ayuda a dispersar las secreciones
emanadas de estas zonas velludas pueden
servir para identificar por ejemplo
varios estudios muestran que la gente
puede identificar el olor de sus axilas
como el de personas cercanas a ellos
el tipo de definitivo de pelo humano
destacable es el vello que nos cubre no
sabemos si este vello Tiene algún
propósito en Sí pero los folículos
capilares crecen de bancos de células
madre esenciales que reparan piel dañada
de una herida también son zonas
importantes de terminales nerviosas que
transmiten señales de tacto suave al
cerebro de hecho aunque más fino los
humanos casi tenemos la misma densidad
capilar que simios de tamaño comparable
no obstante toda esta charla sobre la
desnudez humana no estamos tan pelones
como nos vemos
quieres seguir aprendiendo sobre el
cuerpo humano con este video Explore Qué
causa la picazón o con este video
aprenda Cómo se forman las caries
[Música]